a good time a dozen hands up to the sky
we gonna toast you now can't let it fade
we got a spark a little I led away I'm
counting down and do a starter and again
we come to play
yeah we
[Music]
[Music]
feels like I've been walking
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Wednesday it's hump day our
favorite day of the week hump someone
you love hump a tree hump your dog
that's what I did last night all night
long this week is just breezing by
thanks to the new year yeah that's so
true I love taking a Monday off for the
holidays nothing really gets my loins
girded as much as a Monday off actually
a Friday off what do you think's better
Monday off for sure because Fridays and
easy workday already everyone's like has
high hopes everyone's in a good mood
like everyone is just so mean on Monday
that's actually a very astute
observation skip over Monday all the
time well we hope you're enjoying
Wednesday Jackie and I are obviously
here to deliver you know you know we got
to do we're delivery man we are delivery
boys but before we do that I would like
to make two announcements one of them
sad and one of them is happy the first
announcement is in regards to my Chicago
shows that are intended to be this
weekend I had two shows scheduled
October 5th in Chicago if you bought
tickets please check your email the show
has been postponed to December 19th 20th
and 21st I'm adding a third show so if
you already had tickets to the show you
had from last night until Friday morning
to get your new seats you will be
refunded and you repurchase meet and
greet tickets are available mean greet
tickets include a seat so you don't need
to buy it's not an add-on and because
I'm adding a third show on Friday I'm
going to open up all three shows
whatever remaining seats are left to the
public so I know a lot of people weren't
able to get tickets to my to Chicago
shows so now there is three hopefully
everyone's gonna be able to come I
really apologize for this inconvenience
and I have to let you know that the
inconvenience is due to a reason that is
a good one and I know it's really
annoying that I can't say what the
reason is but just let me know it's a
good one and I think you'll be really
happy that you're gonna get tickets to
these shows because they're gonna be
important that's all I'll say sweet and
then the good news the good news is that
we have been long dragging this out our
next merch drop is on Friday whoo you
guys know we've been working extra hard
rejiggering our entire merch system
there is no more back ordering we
ordered tons of stock for you guys
you're gonna be able to get your orders
in two to three days it's gonna be
really good
Premium stuff new designs it's really
exciting so thank you for your patience
yeah you'll be seeing some of those
designs soon keep an eye out on
Instagram and our social media channels
on society's premium on Friday we will
unlock the store at the end of this show
we attic sure you're watching live on
Friday and hopefully we ordered terms of
quantities so things shouldn't sell out
so they might so just make sure to be in
tune yeah like you don't have to be so
quick but don't be slow because you
might not get the size or the exact item
that you want so but if you're watching
live now that bodes well for you
watching live on Friday we'll see you
then but we order generous quantities
because honestly we no longer want to
have the store closed we're gonna keep
the store open for forever with you know
the best selling items the sweatshirts
the pop sockets the hats the basic stuff
and then we're gonna have drops pretty
regularly with different themed
collections yeah so stay tuned Friday's
gonna be a good day better than usual
Friday you know because it's every great
BTU yeah oh dude we have a story as BTS
making a return no did they go somewhere
like went on hiatus and like then they
came back a day later like now they're
on the cover of variety like talking
about how they've conquered the pop
world that conquered the kpop world and
now they've got their eyes set on a
Grammy it was the dumbest article the
other day they could totally win a
Grammy they took five minutes off what
can't they win if they've conquered the
pop world on the kpop world it wouldn't
a Grammy mean that they've conquered it
to be very true
conquered it yet very true I just want
to say I'm gonna talk about a hiatus
let's talk about one direction one month
just not a hiatus you better talk about
a hiatus let's talk about the Jonas
Brother it's true seven years seven
years yes Wow
and you know what not a moment too soon
not a moment too soon
well we have some really big stories for
you today so I think we should use to
jump right in
should we I think so I don't know what
do you want to talk about the fact that
like we all had migraines last night and
went to sleep early and took various
sleeping aids like I took Advil PM
which I know PM no I know that a Fuxi
weapon like it doesn't for me oh my god
I got so high off Advil PM once I was
also like really sick so I just think
like I was in the weird head space and
Ben didn't realize that they took Advil
PM and I stayed up all night having this
conversation with him about healthy it
was the reincarnated spirit of our
father and he thought it was like so
sweet
then I told 1xa like I didn't remember
what he was talking about and that I was
high on drugs and he was like really
upset oh you know what I actually did
have a few moments when I was so I got a
migraine while we were on the phone at
like 8 o'clock and I couldn't look it
was like one of the worst ones where you
almost want to throw up yeah have you
ever thrown up for a my for my migraine
Oh Ben has um does it make you feel
better no it actually makes me feel
worse because you're now much for and
now you're dehydrated yeah okay I'm glad
I didn't throw up so it's just letting
now I couldn't be on my phone I couldn't
watch TV I don't know what Real
Housewives was on last night and I
couldn't watch and I was like falling
asleep at every like 10 minutes I was
like spooked to wake up I know and I
thought there was like the doc was gonna
just be like standing there so maybe
that was the Advil PM effect but overall
I got 12 hours of sleep so I should be
feeling good today Advil PM man that's
crazy drug so not a crazy drug is night
but I took what nyquil last night
usually I don't have an issue with it
but I did take it at like 11:30 which is
kind of [ __ ] but I felt my throat
hurting and I was like I kind of just
want to try and nip this in the bud so I
took it and like when I say self in dead
last night like I like when I shut my
eyes it just went black like there was
no dream there was no like light like it
was just nothing there and then I woke
up at 9 whatever 8:45 and I was like I
woke up and I was just like I thought it
was Friday I had no idea where I was
what it was like there's a guest I'm
Friday and I thought I had woken up late
I was like holy [ __ ] like there's a
guest I missed it but like freaking out
and I had no idea where I was and when I
sleep usually my blankets are everywhere
like I have to really fully remake my
bed when I woke up this morning it was
literally just like my bed like just
moved and you just put it back like I
was literally like this like a crime
scene yeah we're like body-snatched
yeah how weird is that Chris it's crazy
well leap AIDS man [ __ ] you up
yeah but you get some sleep so yeah
again it's made yeah so I'm feeling good
I'm ready to deliver well I didn't take
a sleep aid and I'm feeling tired so no
no I thought you were going to I was
thinking about it this is having
terrible anxiety but I was up all night
like answering people's questions about
the Chicago red chicken and I want to
leave them in the dust I'm really trying
my best because I know how inconvenient
it is so I was gonna go to sleep early
and then it was just too much going on
and I needed to be there for everyone
because I [ __ ] up their weekends and
again so sorry about that understood
well it's time to deliver in the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of here
toast now in the words of the man from
the Lankan commercial in the back of the
cab it is time but it's not time because
I have to let everyone know that today's
episode is brought to you by Vistaprint
your next big opportunity is coming
right now and we're here to help you own
the now with free shipping on any
business card in any quantity choose
whatever style finish shape or paper you
like and get free shipping and because
you can pick the colors fonts designs
and images it means you can create
something as unique and compelling is
your business
the you the morning chest is the most
compelling business out there and I need
a business card that translate
translates that unique wit u n-- acuity
uniqueness unique uniqueness okay unique
you plug your information and log logo
into hundreds of fresh designs tailored
to your type of company or upload your
own original layout pick the paper stock
style and quantity that's right for you
you can even upgrade to its unique touch
with rounded corners order and receive
your cards with free economy shipping
you can feel good knowing that
vistaprint users only carefully selected
inks and responsibly sourced paper
stocks your satisfaction is 100%
guaranteed or your money back
they'll make it right Vistaprint wants
you to be able to own the now in any
situation which is why our listeners
will get free shipping on all business
cards any style any quantity just go to
vistaprint.com enter promo code toast
for free shipping on all business cards
any style any quantity limited time
offer on the now at vistaprint.com promo
code toast thank you guys
there's nothing more important than
having a business card and you only know
that when someone asks you for a
business card and you don't have one
because you're degenerate who doesn't
have a real business right so get your
business cards it's time get
professional sign on get professional
sign get your [ __ ] together bro totally
ok calling everyone like bro like dude
and I think it's because when I was in
Malibu like hanging out with like
different new people like you kind of
adapt like how they talk and like I
think a lot of you were single thing bro
there was a you know says it Lauren
Elizabeth Warren Elizabeth she's like
bro that's so crazy and I'm like yeah
now I'm just fine that I'm like talking
like her got it suits her yeah well
she's like cool blonde and she like
lives in California where they could say
bro and it doesn't suit a New Yorker
look I got into bed last night I'm like
bro I was the concert
like what yeah dude Surf's Up I'm like
Cody Simpson now totally oh also update
to our story yesterday which was a lot
of speculation that Miley Cyrus was
spotted hooking up with Cody Simpson in
Malibu according to one of our toasters
further update is that Miley Cyrus last
night started following Cody Simpson on
Instagram further making us feel like
the story we reported was definitely
true
totally true okay this first story I
need to just get right into because
rumor has it and by rumor I mean TMZ and
then everyone else that Kylie Jenner and
Travis Scott are taking a break from
their relationship and I know that TMZ
is not always reliable when it comes to
the Kardashians Kris Jenner like is in
cahoots she's a CEO they're like if
that's true you wait Kylie Jenner and
Travis Scott are both single again the
couple is walking away from their
relationship for now TMZ has learned
source is connected to the now exes say
they haven't been together publicly
since his look mom I can fly documentary
premiered in Santa Monica on August 27th
loud that was already over a month ago
time flies time really flies cuz I was I
read they weren't together and over a
month I'm like but we just talked about
how stunning they look together at the
premiere yeah over a month ago no and I
was just having a meeting let's just
make everything about myself about my
next tour oh my god when can you start
but you gotta wait 18 months I'm like
why like what am I gonna do for a year
and a half and they're like you have to
think about it like think of time flies
so fast like if I just saw someone a
year ago like I'm probably not gonna see
them again yeah so I got away they two
months that's like I'm pretty sure Kacey
Musgraves is coming back to New York on
her tour are you guys to go to Radio
City are you guys gonna go but when did
we see her last I saw her in chanyeol
January I know we saw her in Dallas oh
yeah we've been groupies the first but
the rule is 18 months in the same city
yeah so no but she was in New York in
January so why don't you coming back I
think before the end of the year yeah
it's just so special and also has been
fortunate in the Grammy like now she is
just such a bigger I think she's an
anomaly right no she's been touring for
so long because the album was so
successful and she did a huge tour and
like it kept growing and growing and
adding shows and then she won the Grammy
so it's like she had to redo the whole
tour because now all these people know
about her yeah must be exhausting okay
but back to the most devastating news of
the day I agree with you that TMZ is
not making this up out of nowhere that
like this was Chris approved news and
it's making me really sad however what
was also approved is the fact that this
is just a break this is not a break up
I wonder what's going on and I kind of
was feeling like she might be pregnant
again after she was in the hospital of
all montreux and when like I'm there
were stories about how big of a deal
this bomb on thing wasn't she wouldn't
have just missed it for nothing so I was
feeling like she was pregnant again but
this doesn't really jive with that so
actually when I was reading this story
like I didn't really care um and it kind
of made me realized this like overall
vibe within the Kardashian family is
like they don't really like care about
their like relationships with like
husbands like all they care about is
their kids and like so well I'm sad that
Carly doesn't have whatever like she got
a kid like that's all that matters and I
feel like they care so much about like
future generations of Kardashian's and
the men are just like accessories at
this point and I love that like that's
so feminist and they're also just like
necessary to have these children and
they love so much but yeah it's not the
end goal I feel that way too about them
so it's not like the biggest so now all
Kris Jenner cares about is that like she
is literally 13 grandchildren now she
doesn't give a [ __ ] that none of her
kids have like husbands no and I feel
like Kylie we said she wanted to be a
mom for so long she's not always like
talking about you know being a hopeless
romantic right and she wants to be a
business like she's a businesswoman and
a mountain like maybe a girlfriend wife
right they're so realistic like
long-term like accept what Kim and Kanye
have is very special and they're like
really the only ones long-term like
happily ever after like when you're at
that level is really rare and I'd love
that they don't like make it a priority
like they love their kids they love
their businesses and they love their
family and like if a man comes that's
great but it's not the priority and I
think that's like so epic I totally
agree I feel the most that way for Chloe
and even Courtney yeah and then Kim and
Kanye that would be like the saddest
breakup but remember when there are all
those rumors that they were getting
divorced yes that she was on the phone
with the divorce lawyer but it's like
even if they got divorced I don't see
her like being heartbroken eating ice
cream and drinking wine you know I just
see her like moving along no actually I
see her being like devastated that her
family's broken up like now she has four
kids like they are this unit and the
kids like look so much like Kanye like
in the dancing yeah and the Courtney has
three kids but they were always like a
broken home essentially like all these
four kids of Kanye and Kim have ever
known is like a loving family
actually be sad and no it would be
really sad but I agreed that it's not
like this huge loss because they have so
much and they're all so grateful for
what they have yeah no I just think like
it the more I like see the more I just
love like I've been really thinking
about their family I'm like a
subconscious level like I just I love
them I love them this new season is so
good in last week's episode was so good
and and I feel as though we learned a
lot about Kylie was there another
episode after the boat prank they took a
hiatus till next week which is weird cuz
there was only like two episodes at the
premiere we're time for a midseason
break right because it's like beginning
of season brain um and I just know that
Kylie's got her head on straight she's
out her priorities in order and whatever
she's doing she'll be okay but I'm sad
because I love I love their family and I
just want happiness for her and I just
want to know the economical breakdown of
the EDL because I can't imagine that
Kylie takes any money because she
doesn't film but just Kendall like
sometimes she's in it all the time and
then she's never it no candles
definitely gets like I think they get
equal cut they get equal cuts and I
think I should out they shouldn't get
equal cuts because Khloe Kardashian has
put that show on her back for five
seasons I agree but then when you start
I know it's been during equal cuts
it's just slippery slope and sometimes
Khloe puts it on her back but sometimes
Kim does some Courtney's that [ __ ]
punching not recently that's true
recently just in terms of airtime there
was actually a BuzzFeed article like
which Kardashian has appeared in the
most minutes and it was obviously Khloe
there was like a couple seasons when
everyone was having kids and like Chloe
that wasn't there yet where she
literally put that show on her back like
doing the dumbest subplots with MJ with
Chris with Scott like Scott like with
everyone and it just sucks that she
could pay more yeah I agree but I think
she also enjoys it more than some of the
others well because she's in naturally
and her personality like it's never like
I think Courtney's deeply misunderstood
like everything that comes out of her
mouth sounds like the most entitled
privileged like garbage ever but I'm
sure that's not her intention yeah so I
think Khloe like had such good reception
because she's just like a fun everyone
wants to be with Khloe she's a goodtime
gal yeah so I do think she's the most
comfortable and getting positive
feedback like makes you more inclined to
do something also Kim has in the past
few seasons really picked up where like
Khloe left off now that Khloe's a mom
Kim is another one doing like stupid
subplots was yeah
Jonathan yeah yeah Jonathan you're happy
to see it though yeah me too
okay are you ready for our next story
it's another story about an
international prankster oh my god I saw
and I'm very upset about it Justin
Timberlake has been tackled by prankster
be tall
steady ook at the Louboutin show and
this is the same guy who picked up Gigi
Hadid last year uh close he's such a
little [ __ ] he tried to kiss Will Smith
on the mouth he gave Ciara a pantsless
hug outside bomb on show in 2014 he
ambushed Kim three times
oh yeah the pranks happening in one week
Jackie that that meme of Kim like in a
crowd of people like in that white dress
being that guy that's from him yeah I
mean he obviously didn't watch
yesterday's show where we talk about
like the just pranksters have got to
stop um especially when you're like
getting in in strangers personal space
oh my god no this is so insane and so
disrespectful and like honestly you're
just ruining like fandom for other
people because now you know Justin
Timberlake is gonna be less likely to
walk from the curb tis hotel and see
fans and get pictures like he's just
gonna go in the back entrance and no
one's gonna be able to see him yeah
Beyonce that's so close
China has those big celebrities who have
literally like a barricade of security
guards I genuinely don't get it no it's
so crazy like poor Jessica Biel just
like looking over at her husband like no
man left behind
yeah but she's like I'm out of here yeah
she really was like this able to tried
to kiss Miley no I don't think so
because it doesn't say it in this er
tickle I think there's a couple
pranksters out there on the loose who
thinks that this is a cool thing to do
and I just we need to reiterate that
it's not now them getting like press
coverage it's gonna inspire the next
generation of idiot influencers like who
want to make out with people like it's
just what do you think is one of the
worst prank like to be
ggot was picked up to have your fashion
show be ruined by a crasher to try and
be kissed or should like be tackled um
ooh the kiss I think kiss but then you
threw in a wrench with tackled because
like that sounds Paige well that's what
the guy tried to do to justice in the an
assault yeah I think the I guess the
best kind of prank is a fashion show
ruining because like no one's getting
hurt and no individual is being like
threatened right there's no victim -
yeah
yeah it's a lot of people but on a
smaller scale
yeah the pantsless hug is strange very
specific I just ain't nobody got time
for these prayin pranksters are out of
control they really are and it need to
be rattled up and taken to the isolation
cabin it's really like a Paris thing it
happens yeah like I guess I don't want
to give anyone any ideas but there's
less this doesn't happen to somebody so
often when they're in LA we're at New
York Fashion Week right I don't know we
got a beefed-up security man oh yeah no
and then it's just like everything gets
more exclusive more whatever because of
these [ __ ] and you're ruining for
the people who like wanna be there and
enjoy yeah and all those fans who like
line up and wait out ways to take
pictures and like livestream and that
like they get so much joy from it it's
like you're ruining it you're ruining it
for that right because the next time
that Justin Timberlake has to go
somewhere he's just gonna go to the back
alley and go straight like he's not
gonna go through the front door where
all the people are waiting for him yeah
rightfully so because he's feeling
threatened his security is in jeopardy
yeah oh and by the way like it's not
funny oh right that's the best part like
it's a comedy right the prank on the
Kardashians where Chris fake got tackled
like that was [ __ ] funny yeah but
like these pranksters think that they're
comedians and it's just not funny yeah
so something to think about so get a
life okay Nikolai's what was it um his
name was Vitaly say his name Vitaly okay
you Masha
no that's good that's a little that's a
little extreme sorry I got I got my like
my superstitions confused um in some
other international legal and harassment
news Prince Harry issues a statement
against ruthless treatment Megan Markel
has received in the British press Prince
Harry is taking a powerful stance
against the ruthless treatment he says
wife Megan Markel has received in a
British tabloid press quote
unfortunately my wife has become one of
the latest victims of a British tabloid
press that wages campaigns against
individuals with no thought to the
consequences a ruthless campaign that is
escalated over the past year throughout
her pregnancy and while raising our
newborn son he said in a statement the
prince went on to say that he and Megan
have quote continued to put on a brave
face as so many of you can relate to I
cannot begin to describe how painful it
has been his statement comes as the
couple
launches legal action against the mail
on Sunday the mail like daily mail uh
yeah isn't that the Daily Mail it's a
mail
maybe they call it the mail in in
Brandon yeah
this is so interesting just because like
from my perspective I feel like me and
maybe it's cuz we're in America I feel
like American media loves Meghan Markel
and I think like the people love Meghan
Marco so I don't really know what he's
talking about but I gather then there's
a different situation going on in London
yeah I feel like I know when he's
talking about we see all these articles
about like petty [ __ ] between the hey
and personally I skip over it because
I'm just like you haven't absolutely no
insight into what goes on right there
they're literally queens and kings
there's no way that someone journalist
knows what's going on right but I guess
it really affects them and it's totally
worse in the UK for them and I'm really
glad that they're taking a stand because
it's a bunch of [ __ ] same but like
what do you think that like they'd be
above it right like you're the queen do
you really give a [ __ ] what people
magazine saying about you no I I don't
know I it must be really bad if it right
cuz you know what they could like really
tune it out but it must be at a level
where it's impossible to to now but like
they don't even have phones how do they
know I don't know they probably get the
paper and every morning it's like her
doing something like some rumor where
she's doing something wrong you see they
got the paper I do because they they
can't be so out of touch why they don't
have any real like political but they
represent the people they have to know
what's going on on the ground one would
they s one would things yeah so I do
think it's bad I think you think that he
is very scarred and wants to protect
Meghan at all cost right well that's
what it is like this is triggering for
him because this is exactly how it
started with his mom who eventually
ended up dead because of it allegedly
right so I'm glad he's doing what he
needs to do protect our girl yeah you
know but like what why didn't we go
through something like this with Kate
who's arguably more of a media sensation
because she is actually going to be
queen I don't know I feel as though Kate
like plays the game a little bit more
she's willing to like obey yeah and she
knows she's gonna be queen she doesn't I
mean they say all these things that like
the nail polish in the cross legs and
the skirts in the rows and I guess Kate
really abides by those Royals I don't
know if those are
girls and if Megan's breaking them but
like she's allowed to because she's not
quick she's American so it's like the
bar is lower for Megan so she like does
less she does less but then she's held
to the same standard as someone who's
gonna clean when she's not right because
like William has never had to issue a
statement like this has he
I don't think so does the media love
Kate Middleton in the UK I would be
interested to know I feel like they do
maybe a share for us to understand
because I don't see it like the way
right and what's the dynamic because I
know Kate Middleton is technically a
commoner even though she was like a very
wealthy like she went to the same
College as Prince William so like she's
not a commoner but technically she's a
commoner and I think that that was like
a controversial thing at the time in the
Megan Markel came in here like me and
like yo I'm divorcing like nobody cared
that Kate Middleton was Commodore
anymore
right right I don't know but I just put
here in America it's like we're team
routine Megan that's our girl right yeah
suits you watch suits my girl well now
like when you go back and watch scenes
of her like being rattled in the book
stacks you know like it's [ __ ] pretty
say you know that scene because I
literally watched one second of one
episode and she was in the stacks
getting her freak on and she's literally
kissed the black hood right right in a
hallmark movie in a Hallmark yet you
know what I realized about his character
he's always like the first boyfriend in
the movie who like you know he's like
the city slicker and yeah he's the
[ __ ] and he always they never have
those like usually the league doesn't
kiss two people in the movie but
whenever he's in the movie he always
kisses his girlfriend I noticed it in
another movie too just something to
think of formulas being broken yeah also
a lot of the comments are saying that
the tabloids are way harder on Megan
because they're racist because she's
half black Oh which is very possible and
really [ __ ] up it's true
totally I'm really I'm really here for
Harry you have our full support BJ but
that baby is so [ __ ] cute and now
that there's a bet involved I agree we
should she should have stopped yes and
now that there's a baby and this affects
the baby and I think he sees himself in
this bed there and to the bevor Megan is
Diana you know right right right the
young brother is young Harry right and
Megan is Diana and now he's doing what
he wishes someone would have done nip
this in the bud snatchler to the press
and taking legal action and I'm all
about it that you go girl
and she's Devorah like she's the first
black royal she's the first divorce
royal like she squirts American royal Oh
true I thought she was Canadian for a
while but she's just like she didn't
like a Hoover I was the only one it's
not unjustly he's very it's very
confusing I love her she's a little
Jewish yeah you haven't heard that
that's not like everyone there's a
website do or not do and it's like every
exact Efron his great-grandmother
okay come on is Jewish no but you could
type in Paris Hilton Jewish
she's totally Jewish no but there is
like some sort of school of thought
where Megan Merkel is like 1/8 Jewish or
some weight so weight back to Megan
Barroso because she has those things and
I think like the British people consider
it like a disruption in their bloodline
like they're like mad at her for some
reason like [ __ ] off like the British
people honestly are entitled and they
need to get new too you know but the
press as you know doesn't always speak
for the people very true George around
the people sorry the problem within the
press
yeah you're right you right you right
right you're right you're right so just
as Noriega Marco Jesse's for making
Marco feel like I was particularly hard
on her during her wedding mostly just
because I was steeper didn't extreme
jealousy that she like went from being
an out-of-work actress to being a
princess like and no she'll never have
to work another day in her life and
she'll never have to fly commercial
again and like her kids will be set for
life are you guys commercial oh please
he does sometimes play me whenever and
some on the back okay but Megan anybody
went the whole plane Megan and the kid
are never flying commercial I can say
that with absolute certainty okay well
apparently she's not the first american
peter phillips his wife i don't know who
that is though she Wharton was American
divorcee and you saw what happened to
her Wallis Simpson Megan Marco they were
ousted so she's actually was never a
royal it's a whole thing on the crown
round yeah I'm sure yeah big deal but
also he was like a Nazi so makes you
think anyways are you ready for our next
story
speaking of bullying Instagram rolls out
a new feature to help fight bullying no
they're always like doing things that
don't help you know okay this is an
interesting one as I hear it out here
them out earlier this year Instagram
head Adam oh sorry declared that the
social network wants to lead the fight
against online bullying on Wednesday the
social media platform announced a new
effort in that daunting task it's
rolling out a globally a feature called
restrict a tool that it's been testing
since July when you restrict another
user comments on your post from that
person are only visible to them and not
to other people
restricted users won't be able to see if
you're active on Instagram at any given
moment or if you've read their direct
messages Oh
users can also opt to make a restricted
person's comments show up for others by
approving their comments so it's
actually constantly putting people in
timeout yet no but it's like the person
who's restricted like thinks that
they're taking you down and that
everyone's seeing what they have to say
and they feed they're getting that
feeling of being a troll but they get
none of the you know they don't get the
platform because you're hiding them it's
like an invisibility cloak but you can
lock them that it makes them go crazy
and start another account on their
friends account and see that they're in
their comments not showing up yeah but
if you're a popular person you have a
lot of comments like you have to sift
through like words of comments and this
is a step in the right direction I
really like it I'm gonna use it yeah me
too oh my god I live for blocking people
it's like my favorite activity ever Jax
Taylor taught me how to properly block
he blocks literally everyone like there
are toasters cool right in the toaster
screw up like we've never spoken to
Jackson and I feel like it's a lodge by
Jax they're like yeah maybe he just
blocks locks locks I go through like
phases of blocking where I'm like
sometimes I'm like you know what I'm not
gonna block this person like let them
say what they want and then other times
I'm like this is my page this is my safe
space get out of here goodbye I know I J
sir I said go tell you I feel two ways
about it too like I don't even want this
person who's like the troll the [ __ ]
between my toes to even know that I
acknowledge their presence and go in
their profile and pressing block right
but then sometimes I always block when
it when it's a thin step because it's
like if you don't have the courage to
say what you want or the only conviction
from your profile you don't get the
platform to say it but if you're gonna
if you want to come out here from your
personal account and say some stuff you
know I admire the bravery and I'll
probably keep you on yeah if you want to
come at me with a picture of your kid
and your Bible program in your bio like
that's [ __ ] brave and obviously I
admire the bravery but by the way that
never happens because then you know you
even if they're a private account
she probably cabin is somewhere in the
middle sometimes I'll block sometimes I
won't because they're still not being
brave if you're private but if you're a
public account but then you're they're
opening themselves up to a world of
criticism and it's like let me see your
photos yeah I mean II PI by the way let
me see your vote do we have it as a
story about that veterans funeral no did
you hear about it no my god it's so hear
this obituary like went viral because oh
it would said this former veteran passed
away he had no immediate family all are
welcome to attend the ceremony and it
was like in the back of a local magazine
like so sad like it literally went viral
thousands of people showed up like ton
to hit a hole veteran ceremony for him
yesterday a bunch of people posted in
the toasters a bunch of toasters went
cuz it was in Florida it was like such a
sad story and like it's just like a
happy ending and like the pictures of
like all these motorcades like tons of
people like it was beautiful and they
had like a televised like it was sick
like not sick but you know I mean it was
huge yeah that's awesome
I saw the beginning of the story where
they were people were gonna show up and
I didn't I didn't see the actual funeral
I was like so proud of the toasters
because so many of them went and I'm
when I saw the thing going around that
like it was going by real I'm like I
really hope people show up 22 I was so
sad I was gonna fly like it was so
depressing no that's really sweet
oh I can't wait to look at that some
good news do you want to hear some other
good news yeah because this is some
interesting health news blade helicopter
sharing app to speed transplant organs
blade has begun deploying helicopters in
the Big Apple to quickly transport human
organs for emergency transplants oh
that's so smart are they getting the
organs from like you know people donate
organs and then they like someone dies
and they'd like we found a liver yeah go
into surgery in the next five hours
hospital hospital
like so similar like jaws California no
you can't take a helicopter to
California so it's open like the
tri-state area but it takes wherever to
get places yeah the helicopter sharing
app better known for flying summer
beachgoers from New York City to the
Hamptons has teamed up with NYU Langone
health to give doctors faster access to
vital organs suppost has learned
blades 90-plus helicopters have been
made accessible for dispatch between NYU
and hospitals up to 400 miles away got
it sometimes a medical team will fly to
another hospital to procure in Oregon
and other times it will deliver one only
and why you spokesperson said with the
new service patients who previously had
to wait five hours for an organ
now only have to wait three hours set
executive director of the NYU at Lang go
and Transplant Institute Oh a long time
in organ transplantation every minute
counts that's true and the shorter the
time that the organ is traveling the
better it will work when it's
transplanted this is just a bit of good
news especially for blade who was never
has a shortage of bad news right down in
the Hudson blade down the river right
also I feel like the winter season is a
bit quieter for them you know people
aren't summery and this is a great use
of helicopters yeah uh who's paying for
it so I'm not sure if it's like a
charitable thing or it's a partnership
so maybe they're you know serviced by
paying a service fee have you been
seeing commercials for NYU Langone no I
mean see so many commercials for like
NYU hospitals and like is it weird to
have a commercial for oz well we do you
know yeah there will always be a need
for a hospital like sadly so well you
know what I'm I'm here for commercials
for hospitals cuz the one time I had to
go to the hospital in the city I
definitely went to the wrong one when
did you go to the hospital I was having
like really bad stomach pains I went to
Bellevue oh that is like the psych ward
do they go there an SVU when like
literally NYU is next door
yeah we were living in Murray Hill back
then yeah yeah I think if I ever went to
have to go to the hospital not gonna wet
poo poo poo
I would go to Lenox Hill because I feel
as though that's where like a lot of
celebrities go see there's a far uptown
like if I'm in an emergency I'm gonna go
to the nearest one you're gonna go to
NYU beautiful anybody use one it's
actually beautiful on this like Park
Avenue corner and when Charlotte York
gave birth there in the corner the
corner unit of Lenox Hill Hospital yes
it's a sorry it's a stark I think
Beyonce gave birth I just took over a
whole floor allegedly a legend that's a
stark because the Astros were born there
oh yeah yeah that's they're born there
yeah so I don't even know what was
saying that oh I forgot yeah no it's my
birth place place the Camaro on a
birthright trip
thanks a lot exhale very exciting well I
think that's some great news too and the
news of the day yeah I know you didn't
watch um
Real Housewives of Orange County so I
won't spoil it for you but it was a
rather good episode quite emotional
highs lows laughs cries and I just
further
feel justified in my real love for Kelly
Dodd like I'm thinking she's such a
misunderstood person
like she's constantly being driven to
the point of being crazy like she's not
a crazy person yeah yeah and then we can
watch ovens live with Jenny McCarthy
Gina Christian Heiner and Tyler C was
the bartender and obviously the first
thing that shows he was whether he was
single or not and he was like really
struggling to get words out so do you
think he's with Gigi based on his answer
no oh he was like reluctant to say and
then he was a gown single well yeah it
was quite shocking did you see what he
said about how he had to hide his boners
just snatchler update us basically that
he liked his pants were so tight that
they kept everything in check and that
one time like they were like making out
heavy and they were like trying to get
them to leave and he was like no and
then eventually they had till even he
was like had a boner and she was like
you want me to walk in front of me and
he was like no it's fine and he's like
embrace it and walked with it on camera
but it got cut oh my god well you know
that's something I never really thought
about like about logistics about
bachelor contestants I never thought
about boners you have so much sense and
no I don't have a dick so at what point
you get the boner look when you're
kissing like yeah Whitney hold on the
beginning not always it's been done man
yeah yeah I guess like some guys can I
hold it down but yeah they do some hot
and heavy make outs on that show they
straddle and then they're yeah and then
they're just like okay bye let me go
that's why maybe they make out and pulls
a lot because you would get shrinkage I
don't think it's easy to get a boner in
oh and a pool or hot tub interesting
that might be why they're constantly
yeah but then in hot tubs interesting
interesting we definitely could use some
more logistics about and then the Alex
Factor contestant we have on the alcohol
doesn't help I mean doesn't hurt yes you
the more you drink the more impotent you
become yeah and is it impossible to like
hide the boner you do a tuck you tuck it
under your belt but yeah you know
whatever because from 6:00 to midnight
that's what the kids say is that what
they call it yeah cuz if you think of a
clock it goes from 6:00 to midnight yeah
yeah yeah well it would be like from
6:00 to 3:00 to midnight 6:00
you're down yeah 3 that's not a time 3
is this way yeah Thank You Margot the
six nine no also this
man this to the right 3 is to the left
12 is up oh oh okay that's like 6:00 to
midnight midnight it like like that give
it that that's how a clock moves
it does rise it's like a circle no okay
anyways I have to watch the episode
because I still believe that him and
Gigi are dating anything that if he said
he was in a relationship then that would
cement for everyone that they're
together and that's not what they want
they still want this air of mystery so I
think he had to he had to Jenny McCarthy
was sitting in the first chair and I
definitely got this vibe that like she
thought her [ __ ] didn't stink like now
she's on the math singer just robably
getting paid so much money and I feel
like for a while and her career she had
like each hit like when she did that
reality show with Johnny Wahlburgers
like it was just it was not good so I
think like now sheets like back and
better than ever and like she was being
a little annoying like they played this
game threesome I forget what it was
called it was like they went to a bunch
of celebrities and asked if she and
Johnny we have a threesome with them and
they have like hot men hot women she's
literally said no to every single one
she's like I love Donnie's penis but
that's not the [ __ ] question play the
game Johnny Phoenix is still there right
it's hypothetical like it was so
annoying because basically it's like not
a spoiler but Bronwen at the end of
episode admitted that like her husband
like have regular three sounds like with
women that they know like friends of
friends and the girls were like so
confused asking her like so many
questions like in your house she's like
no no no and they're like I think what
she said in an end was like she said it
and then I think she immediately
regretted it because she was like
someone's like gee watch threesomes are
you do threesomes and she was like she
really regretted saying it and then
there hasn't so many questions and I
think basically the conclusion was that
she every couple years she gets the you
know the urge to like [ __ ] a girl and
she's not gonna do it without her
husband so the husband is not allowed to
[ __ ] the other girl okay and then I
heard that a girl just like do stuff and
then like her husband he's haven't got
it oh man I can't wait to watch yeah it
obviously was like a huge window into
her marriage you know for sure but like
finally some authenticity from her yeah
cool
it's actually true like you know she was
drunk they were they finally had a good
night at Miraval
and also what last night's episode
really made me wanna go to Mary Ball one
of those real let's say they have a hot
tub and a pool like it looked so nice
and Kelly didn't to go to one activities
if she want to see Becky and she was
just like they send Jolie like in the
hot tub it was beautiful views like no
incest Canyon
I would even like look forward to doing
some of that meditation so I do you know
okay maybe we should like do something
like that like a little Miraval
experience yeah okay the toast smear of
all week okay I have to catch up and
then Real Housewives of Dallas is on
tonight yes so exciting and oh and some
some more guest updates because a bunch
of the testers we're demanding the
column from below Jack come on the Cho's
so you asked we deliver he's coming on
next week what day Tuesday Tuesday very
excited even though there's no below
deck reunion this year they used to do
them I know they didn't do it I wonder
why I don't like feel the need for a
reunion but they were very popular and
they weren't a big deal they were in the
watch I was like studio like it was just
like a fun way to end the season it just
wasn't complete I feel that well we'll
get all of our outstanding questions he
will answer oh I want to know if he's
seen June I have such a soft smart I've
worked like ships him in June I know so
do I there's both such precious gems
June June Hanna June June and then also
this Friday correct we have Cameron
Wescott Dallas prestige joining us here
on the toast I'm like a little nervous
because I just like don't know what to
expect I feel like she's like a
chameleon you know yeah I'm actually
really excited to meet her I'm so glad
she's coming now because I become a huge
fan of hers on the show Joe and I do
enjoy like fangirling as opposed to you
know feeling conflicted yeah like when
we mentally unlock him for the first
time I was very conflicted that she
ended up being like the nicest woman
ever and I respect her so I just judging
based on like how past things have gone
like this I feel like I'm gonna like her
even more after she's done and I look
forward to that experience for myself so
a bunch of good guests coming up
reminder that if you bought tickets my
Chicago show please check your emails
they have been postponed for a very good
reason and tickets are gonna become
available for a third show starting on
Friday 10:00 a.m. Central Time our first
merch shop in a very long time is coming
to you on Friday so make sure you tune
in Friday we got calm and Wescott and
then right after the show ends we are
opening up the merch store for all of
you to get your toasty goods both old
bestsellers will be back in stock so are
any sweatshirts hats pop sockets and
then tons of new items for the
back-to-school season it's
back-to-school themed drop it's actually
making me wanna you know go back to
night school it's definitely making me
like want to have a locker yes what can
I get my magnets and my notebooks you
know yeah it's really good [ __ ] I feel
like you guys are gonna like it's a
stage and a lot of stuff you've been
asking for yes we love you very much
that is all we have for you today thank
you so much for listening to the morning
chose the Millenial morning show we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so feel free to
subscribe like this video give it a
thumbs up leave a comment you know what
to do with that big that but we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so that's iTunes Spotify
stitcher Public Radio I aren't radio all
those apps cast box anything you want we
got it please subscribe to us on the
podcast or leave a review 5 stars about
how beautiful smart we are and we love
you guys so much have an amazing day we
will see you tomorrow
you